[Musique]
nous avons quoi qu'on en
pense l'amour du pays
natal et du Nord à la
Provence on le chante et c'est
normal c'est pourquoi à mon tour j'ai la
chance de chanter un petit coin pour moi
sans égard les GAM il montant sont
toujours
remontant même en
redescendant les rues de mes n
m il sont le cœur
ardent le cœur et tout le restant tant
qu'ils s'en vont chantant
mais
monant ils s'en vont la mine
pierre droit devant eux dans la
rue et s'il baisse les
papières c'est sur un mollet d'u dans un
coup d'œil ils vous font
l'inventaire des trésors bien cachés par
une
inchéulé g mir montant
sont toujours
remontant même en
redéscendant les rues de
mimes il FT le cœur ardent le cœur et
tout le restant t qu'il s vont chantant
bénir
bonjour mon cher